the covert 19 pandemic has affected the
lives of many young girls for months
schools were closed in hundreds of
countries as a result there's been a
rise in teenage pregnancies the ngo
world vision says as many as one million
girls across sub-saharan africa may not
return to school due to pregnancy here's
the story of one young mother in
zimbabwe
[Music]
thirteen-year-old virginia has their
hands full trying to comfort her
three-month-old baby
tending to house chores and her four
younger siblings
she was 12 when she became pregnant
my aunt was the only one who knew i was
pregnant
when i later decided to stay home from
school
she called my teacher and told her i was
expecting
virginia had hoped the father of her
child an older man would provide for her
community workers say the pandemic has
worsened the problem of child
pregnancies
lockdown led to the abuse of many kids
by people they know or stay with
because people were just in one place
spending more time together
this led to a lot of pregnancies
more than 5 000 school girls under the
age of 18 fell pregnant in one year
alone says the women's affairs ministry
we have been having community outreach
programs throughout the whole nation to
encourage these learners to come back to
school to continue with their education
because it's not the end of the world
sometimes virginia longingly takes out
her old school books
i'm thinking of going back to school and
restarting my grade seven and proceeding
from there
then i'll decide what career path to
take the phone
until then the government's outreach
program is teaching her some skills like
soap making so she can create some kind
of small income to support herself and
her baby
well teenage pregnancy rates are rising
in rwanda partly due to gender norms
that put all the weight of preventing
pregnancy on girls one woman is trying
to change things she's created a video
game that educates teenagers about sex
nestled in the lush rwandan hills
a center for teenage school dropouts who
are already mothers
they train for various jobs here
including shoemaking
i dropped out of school because i was
pregnant
i'm here to learn a trade that will
allow me to feed my child because i come
from a poor family
now they don't want me at home
the man who got me pregnant abandoned me
and shut off his phone
it's a story that more and more rwandan
girls share
entrepreneur abigail gizubizo the ceo of
dope apps aims to educate teenagers with
a video game starring a girl named kiza
kiza must overcome obstacles like men
who offer her money or drugs
gael has added other features as well
including a chat function
i can ask any question i want in the
chatbot
the question i can't ask my parents the
question i can't ask my teacher so it's
a it's a safe space for the young people
to ask any related terrible question so
um
the young people we get we got some
feedback from the young people and they
really enjoyed it because they
feel they are not judged
because they do it anonymously
in this school more than 500 students
have taken abigail's course
where she teaches them how to avoid
unwanted pregnancies and how to play the
keys again
so i've learned that
during adolescence
girls have to be careful
in their relationship with boys
from my side i learned that i have to
advise boys who want to abuse girls not
to do so because we play a big role in
this abuse
prizes for the students who did the best
at the game positive reinforcement
rather than heavy-handed instruction
abigail gizubuzzo hopes these lessons
will stick and that her game helps young
people make informed choices about their
lives
you